he
happy Christmas everyone welcome to the
lobby 2PM
Pacific how you doing how you doing you
feeling good you feeling spooky it's
going to get real spooky here I'm
already terrified by Peter Brown's new
face
hi
by Andy Ban's lack of knowledge that he
was going to be on for the whole show I
am scared of cameras are you scared of
your bowels because you lost I just
downed a burrito bigger than my forearm
Y and by it's not a big forearm to be
fair I'm by Chris waters' sweet hat
thank you hat friend a pleasure hat
friend top of the morning to you vaning
hat right it's uh yeah it is a van Hing
hat but I'm wearing it it is part of a
different costume what's the costume
I'm dressed up as a guy who wears fanny
packs to music
festivals youtil I forgot my fanny pack
though front or back uh side side I feel
like side saddle D really but you won't
go thirsty you put water in there what
water in a fanny pack what is it what do
the fanny pack guy put in his fanny pack
drugs items yeah drugs for children back
man anything you get out that side you
got to you got to tweak it keep you can
you know the contents of the fanny pack
well enough to zip reach in grab them
transfer to your other hand close zip
and then go about your business that
seasoned I guess that's the whole point
PNY pack is knowing what your business
is or let's keep it real you just slide
it
around slide around best yeah I used to
have a sick ass fanny pack you want to
talk about fanny pack do you know how we
what made it sick ass it was huge was it
a backpack that you just wor around your
waist no it was like a production like I
put all my lenses and like all my
batteries
Yeah well yeah all right do you know how
we used to know who was an American
Tourist how did you used to know an
American Tourist fny P really or as we
call them bum
bags that that works too that's a good C
cuz you're a bum if you wear them oh
that's that's why I was you guys feeling
refreshed we did a bunch of crazy stuff
this weekend we had extra Life 2014 our
100 hours of playing video games uh we
did 24 hours here then went to the UK
they did 24 then AU and then back here
for 28 hours and uh you were away I went
to a wedding in Vermont and it was
fabulous it sounded gorgeous with lots
of pretty leaves and things yeah I got
about as much sleep as you guys did
though yeah did you get as wasted as we
did did you make any speeches I did make
a speech and I did yeah did you tell him
to donate to it was a reception it was a
reception night speech and no I did not
because there well there only a few
people there who are Gamespot fans did
you raise over over
$122,000 for Oakland's children hospital
and Research Center Oakland California
the United States of America the world
universe that you guys did that that's
pretty awesome you did and thanks to
everyone who donated uh it was much
appreciated uh highlights of the stream
obviously you taken one for the team
yeah taking a shade for the team was
pretty bones to lose my beard yeah first
time in five years I kind of like it a
little bit yeah you do it I don't know
it was worth it for the but not CLE
you're not like all the way this days
ago but were you did you go big smooth
no I didn't have a big but it was
shorter than this you should touch your
microphone to it give it like
texture and the youan for yeah how long
did you stay for I was two well the
first time turned was long I was there
for like forever and the first night
first night and well well I was here but
then I didn't go on stream until like
lat oh yeah yeah you stuck right not
important Saturday I was there 12 to 12
yeah 12 to 12 you did that's all I could
commit to until midnight yeah was it
yeah yeah it was good my favorite game
oddly enough that we played was the bomb
tennis game that was well it's called
danis now but oh yeah it was Andis cuz I
was good at it but everything else was
danis it was virtue tennis 4 Wast yeah
it was like a virtue of tennis bonus
game where you shot a bomb at each other
pretty good we Samurai gun no we never
got Samurai gun working we play a lot of
gang beasts we play a lot of uh um
fibbage was real too yeah fibbage was
great we kept going back toib play that
that's good times it woke everyone up as
well on tournament woke me up a lot in
the morning I played NBA Jam against
Shawn sea oh my God in the end of that
game we woned on an overtime
three-pointer from John Stockton also
ashick layups sick layups it's written
right on the wall behind you that was sh
M that was one of those triumphant
moments where we get so psyched that
every one wearing headphones and
watching just gets blasted it's so bad
and I apologize every time but so worth
it it was it was like last time you and
Sean were on video together and like
that game like it just felt it in the
room like everyone wants you guys to win
this and we were winning we're playing
against the AI of NBA Jam and we're not
pulling out an easy stomp himount
Victory which we really should have but
it ended up working a lot better cuz we
tied it up and went to overtime the
mailman delivers that's all I'm saying
that's true true and despite
being car Malone had an impressive
amount of dunks that match but it was
John hawton the so-called
with please there's a street named after
him it's all what did I just say hawton
what hawton hawton St you said Haw why
would I even say that the hat is good
man yeah it is it's all those fanny
packs three-pointer pretty cutting off
your circulation yeah thanks to all the
um folks who set up Fen leg again for
setting up the uh Minecraft server which
was as ridiculous as ever this year it
got it was like twice as big as last
like three times maybe as big as last
year just ridiculous amount of stuff so
yeah thank you everyone for donating and
watching uh much appreciated you can
still donate if you want at tinyurl.com
gextra life GS extra life I was about to
say last year's one again speaking of
tiny orls uh if you go to tinyurl.com
Sunset Overdrive sweepstakes that is
tinyurl.com
Sunset Overdrive sweepstakes look at
that the words just appear at you can
win an Xbox One with Sunset Overdrive
we're giving it away oh bam one of those
white ones yeah one of those sweet white
ones on the show right now so you need
to go to that link right now tin.com
Sunset Overdrive sweep Stakes that's
only for you uh wonderful folks who
decided to tune in live and we're going
to give it away on the show but first of
all spooky video games yeah third of all
this point yeah it is it's like yeah
just I'm covering in cobwebs or is I
like to think elderly
pubes and immediately proceeds to rub
them on his face and mouth and mouth a
so is that right yeah that's that's sure
my Double Dragon that's your F man cheu
a little bit all right H I brought my
scary my scariest game I ever done
played in my whole life it's called call
of cthulu Darker corners of the Earth
have you guys ever played this nope you
play this all right I'm going to try and
stretch over here with my cobweb sheath
on are you going to be starting a new
game from scratch I am I want you I Want
You Folks at home to know that before we
got to this menu it did tell us in order
to maximize our cthulu experience to
turn down the brightness so we did our
best to help maximize the cthulu
experience for you uh we've got the mood
lighting some of us got the memo about
wearing costumes and others you
know and Andy I love this um WX and D X
for backwards and then uh s for Action
I'm probably going to change that don't
do that I don't even have an email
action e i don't even work here I just
come in and they don't tell me to you
say you don't have an email yeah you do
it's at cna.com
what the hell is sis a Boy Scout private
investigator whatever's let's be a Boy
Scout be a private investigator it's not
scary enough otherwise you think it's
going to amp up the scares cuz you're Pi
now dude I'm in Arkham Asylum whoa oh
you you are this is the Batman this is
the Pre-Sequel how's this allowed this
is Arkham Asylum Origins forget about
that other game called Arkham asy is
Clive Barker a DC
property yes
okay I think I want to be Deathstroke
for Halloween but I don't think I can
put together the costume you just get
one of those one piece
things I need like some Sweet Shadows
between knee pads and elbow pads and The
Mask I'm going onesie in the dark
corners of the frag you guys I
appreciate your impulse to talk over
this monologue so it's not as spooky but
this guy walks Between Worlds and sees
the true Shadows of things that areain
and have existed forever that's some
good eyes this is like I feel like 2001
maybe did you say those eyes were pretty
good for
2001 yeah yeah they sure figured out how
to do those spheres just in time those
yeah but they move move around it's also
you know anytime you talk about Good
eyes you can't you got to talk about
good
eyelids didn't without good without
eyelids you're just a a ball what is an
eye do you think this guy's going to
hang
himself or is he just he is standing on
a chair he's just
surfing practicing his surf moves it's
like he's not doing so hard
no now he's masturbating a little
bit Andy was injecting a little bit of
yourself into your work
no the words dark corners of the earth
it's the stuff that he said before come
on late Toler cage come on late Toler
cage I can't read cursive I now walk in
the shadows read it but I can't read
it I have no idea where this game drops
you in I remember the first level of
this being absolutely terrifying
though saving
game game tips sure you'll need the tips
proba need some tips 6 and a half years
ago oh spoilers how did he even get to
the situation where he hung himself in a
crazy place by driving in a car to an
asylum if I remember correctly
yes he looks so
Dapper I wonder what you look like if
you're the Boy
Scout he's got a C on you turn up at the
Asylum with cookies that's Girl Scouts
do boys not guys not sell the cookies do
they sell they we s points we sold did
we even sell anything we sold made
crafts and stuff I just made [__] that
was Cub Scouts I made like wooden cars
and race them that's pinew
Derby go you guys are so
American are you [__] on pinewood
derby right now you know how many P
der's best it's like a video game in
real
life you want to revise that comment
about
eyes name's Victor don't can I redact
that he's the leader of this weird look
at this is gesturing with his shotgun oh
God I forgot there's a whole whole other
level before you get to the level that I
wanted to play That's All
Right unable cut
scenes I don't understand why you think
this cut scene would be skippable you
start a new game to like jump in like
why would that cut scene be skiable a
story based game yeah based on actual
books not just some [__] is it based
on Lovecraft stuff here they got the
they got the Lovecraft license they
never made another call of cthulu game
this was the only they ever won Le the
way robt I better check out this ofs
when they translation into in skull
view H did it think
so hey what's
up this dude look kti good sir is it
true what they say about you we're going
to talk yes I am Batman that you've
cracked cases where there was no
evidence you shouldn't believe
everything I planted
evidence right duckid thanks chick learn
a thing or two you'll go far I don't
want to talk to any I'll talk to you as
well hey what's up Jack officer Nichols
will brief you at the top what his eyes
jowls I'm running this is me list jowels
are a tried and true way to increase the
spookiness and or oiness of Any Given
scenario
like everyone looks like they've like
slept in a
week you're really strung out they must
have raised a lot of money for extra
life it though they're sending me in
without a gun to like calm this guy down
who clearly wants is that him there
you're The Negotiator no they did say
check the alley oh [__] oh damn guy got
get sniped damn I think so I don't know
where I'm supposed to run run just run
just spit dead run to the dude dead oh
[__] he disappeared that's even
creepier
turn around let's look at the Carnage if
only you had some
evidence oh two men down I got to plant
some evidence quick just get in there I
feel like you don't need evidence when
the dude literally just shot a cop in
front of you like you're all set
eyewitness accounts are hazy oh my God
tentacles uh that's cthulu too here's a
true story that tentacle painting yeah
that is literally what the carpet at
machine games looks like the Developers
of Wolfenstein the New Order that's a
fact right Andy they had straight up
cthulu carpet throughout their whole
office low this door frame is how
terrifying what the hell is with these
short [__] doors looks almost like a
flaming eye I think that might be a save
point is it if I remember correctly yes
I was right I haven't played this game
as
so looks like a biology textbook
defitely do I have a gun I don't think I
have any guns just go up to the guy and
press action is that him is that the
shooter everyone in this game seems to
be into autoerotic ex fixation
well why seriously what is up with these
doors these doors are half the height of
the ceiling I can't open it poison the
looks of it poisoned this is a weird
part he drank the Kool-Aid what's that
it's going to Ste your literature this
will make interesting
oh wait should I read the journal canot
get over the door height look at look at
the door your head is going to smash
right into you're going to crack your
forehead on it look like what see the
way like my eyesight's going all weird
already no see the way it's like swaying
a bit let's G back to normal there but
basically one of the mechanics in this
game is that he just gets freaked out by
stuff dead I can't see he's dead oh
[__] he gets way more freaked out wake
up he's also
dead where else am I supposed to go
clean yourself up you dead won open I
feel like it's an artifact of the game
being in WID screen cuz look at the the
knobs too they looked kind of stretched
out maybe that's what's happening with
everyone's faces too is they look a
little stretched were you even shooting
at
anymore just the house in
general architecture sucks
dude find find that evidence there he is
hump oh Focus
mode film grain
activated don't shoot I'm
unarmed we've been expecting you
Mr oh what who did who oh what's wrong
with your face that's the bullet wound A
Soldier of Fortune been expecting you
there's like how many of them recogn
whoa who shot him through the window
yeah one of those
assh this game is about police
brutality it won't open H it won't
budge you have to use the is this one of
I think that screen must have might have
just said you have to like
use I better find out what my inventry
button is oh it's I who would have ever
guessed
it God damn
it I got five Keys an s s engraved on
the
head s for spooky all right now we'll
have a dramatic reading of a collation
of G wait oh I don't have narcotic
analgesics yet look at your analog
heartbeat oh yeah look at that
beep I don't think I guess it wouldn't
beep cuz it's anal I'm go down yeah it's
scrolled by that paper clip it's locked
here we go here we
go it's the wrong key oh you son of a
burned here it looks like an eye but the
rest of the pain painting is no it's
unlocked oh I did it that was the key
great oh yeah this is a good place do
some research I love I'm playing an
adventure game while everyone's just
getting shot this should fit the door I
don't understand and all of these photos
all of
them there must be some kind of mistake
watching why would they want me here it
must be an old case something I've
forgotten he's freaking out scr with a
grudge maybe think I've got to think he
freaking out yeah he's he's got to think
anytime you tell yourself you got to
think you know you're in trouble when
was the last time you said I got to
think I got to think like to yourself or
to someone else no to yourself no you
say to yourself with nobody else around
late I got to think out
loud it appears to be I got to think
there are definitely some strange sounds
coming from this side of the room uh-oh
yeah go over to there step in that
mirror
whoa what happened there oh you're
crouching down Sex
Dungeon [__] this is where they do their
tattoos whoa almost never happens in
video games this where to do the tattoos
yeah and also the 2x4 murders must have
fallen and crushed his
skull oh God what's happening
hash 2x for
murder wow their organization is
terrible one of their own
I wonder if he volunteered it's the med
Bay seems like these cabinets are used
for storing chemicals and medical
equipment what the heck is
that oh
God I better ask him if he's okay wait
go get a closeup good god what the hell
is still
alive what happens if I hit this ominous
green button oh you just zap him for
shits and
giggles
is that his that's his heart that's a
pair oh he's definitely dead my bad oh
what his skull open up brains open leod
AMI what's in the other jars were those
potatoes someone running a clock radio
down here his brain stopped moving I
stole that sweet Crystal I'm going to
sell it his brain lungs his lungs has
stopped ventilating oh his heart is
stopped what's this then so they pulled
everything out his stomach stopped
moving
they pulled everything out but he's
still there power and hooked him up it's
cuz I stole the
crystal what's in here this tunnel feels
like collap any
moment I got a thing oh sweet
puzzles also stealing this Crystal it's
too hot to pick
up wow this is quite a
chamber it looks like something's been
removed the house is quite modest in
comparison that's Crystal pop that Cris
something has been removed from there
pop bottles of Chris this is like Zen or
something just go summon an eldrid God
already what do you think is going to
come
up
tentacles a
pony
evidence find some evidence here
quick I kind of remember what happens
here just start saying pargon pargon
chatga chur you'll be
fine well that's kind of weird whoa cool
uhoh you want me to get tattoos a bunch
of
them you've merged our the mere sight of
them cost your brain game
over oh loading
saving wait is this before or after
then I can't tell
is this the Annie Hall years since I
entered that strange house in Boston so
what is it now six months from when he
went crazy but to me it was just 5
months ago oh Amnesia the doctors called
it Amnesia probably brought on by acute
mental stress I don't know there's
nothing acute about what happened there
I remember investigating would you call
it more of an obuse mental stress scre
is that what you're going for EOL
was isos mental stress Bo goes missing
mayor accused of wife's death local cop
Safe child that doesn't make any sense
on the floor Danny REM mind everyone
what game is this again call of dark
corners of the earth it's available on
Steam open yeah it's one of those games
that not many people have play but the
kind of folks who
have were scared by it not that bit at
all but the next area is pretty it's got
some unique first person account did he
say there was something unnatural about
the guy whose empty rib cage was still
keeping him alive did he forget about
the massive Von that came through the
teleporter Von primes I have learned
little of my activities in the years
that followed the I've been able to
piece together the witch cult in Western
Europe my spicious
cult oh so he wasn't in a coma for six
years he was he just can't remember what
he was doing for all that
running around being a messed up agent
of Darkness
Lang my
own when I reawakened 5 months ago
exactly 6 years after entering that
house in Boston no Trace was left to
what had been a secondary
personality I was myself again or at
least what I believe myself was his
other personality cath return to it was
Batman obviously because he was in
Arkham Asylum something weird happened
six years passed in which case he did
all four Batman Arkham games and then he
just woke up in a Cell they had stripped
him of his cape and everything why do I
keep thinking of the word Rock Steady
years I've
told yeah oh he's trying to draw draw
the
thing hello Jack
Walters hello Mr wal is that a wireless
Old Time phone I need your help missing
person I that Bluetooth I don't take
that kind of job listen that's a common
mistake that people of the future think
about people of the past that they
weren't smart or technologically
advanced they were within the bounds of
their
time even had
cigarettes man's greatest
Triumph come on that's how I store
things it's fine scary
part you be casting aspersions on my
video game exctly you want from me Mr
what does aspersions mean it's one of my
St managers you see casting aspersions
is a fancy way of talking talking [__]
talking [__] but call the cthulu dark
corner of the Earth get classy just cast
dispersions it's a little more oque it
like just kind of cast you're not like
what's the spell asojano I don't know
ask K Potter here yeah hey if I have my
glasses on maybe that would have been
funny hold on there a minute I didn't
agree to take
this what the hell what the hell I've
been not working for 5 years I could do
with the dough chat saying we should
have played cve Barker's undying undying
yeah that's not a
scary oh man Eternal Darkness cve bar
Jero is that the shooter yep Jericho
clyve Barker's Y2
Jericho you got a oh man insouth that's
here we go insouth we're going to go to
insouth shit's going to get weird only
one bus goes to enouth everyone in
insouth looks like
come back because the bus is also inbred
like everyone in insouth you're about to
see if you talk the eyelids you're going
to find out why the regular looking
people have weird eyelids now was the
movie like the people of the hill or The
Hills Have Eyes Hills Have Eyes yeah is
it like
people I haven't seen that they're like
all like kind of like amorphous and like
weird looking right yes they look like
they've been banging their cousins
Generations all right and I would narrow
it down to even their immediate family
not
cousins I love this level so
much that movie has a great scene in it
that's like the most intense cinematic
scene even the bus driver speaking weird
yeah I would say
that then the Remake I'm talking about
of course all right let's just pretend
let's role play this let's pretend we've
come to
insouth just want to get away for a week
it's week after E3 you want to calm down
justed up y oh fine just get away away
from games for a while see some local
culture headless shotgun men learn about
line end of the
what what's it's like all right just I
just need to check in all right I'm
sorry you're it's another I know it's
another hotel room it's been a tough
week at E3 in a hotel room but at least
this one won't have Xbox advertising on
the mirror I won't be in Sun overdrive
least Ted price won't be putting posters
in my room while I'm sleeping thank you
could you direct me to the First
National Grocery Store I hear they have
a shop in town I don't know nothing
about that oh well you see I'm looking
for a young lad called Brian Burnham I'm
a friend of the stop talking to this
dude he's not going to give us the
information who you talking
about obviously I better check the man
has not heard of such Concepts as soap
let alone grocery stores and people get
me no place fast I know was this
bus better check in right this place
looked a lot different on Trav velocity
even my name's G hotel.com just visit me
you don't say Sir Gilman Charlie Gilman
because I've got gills this here Hotel
of an evening you got any
rooms i' not rightly know that for sure
all haveit cleaning rooms at present
thems from out of town can leave a
horrid
mess what you don't know if you have
rooms available in your hotel this is
fishy well
sometimes I need a room and I'm
desperate and I'll come
back come back I want to go upstairs and
see if there's a room I find one myself
I'll just walk in and see if anybody's
busy hello is anyone sleeping here okay
I will now sleep
here the the same Carpenter the same
architect made this place [__] tiny
jump down here God damn
it whoa you exerted yourself a little
too
much all right friend off no rooms it is
the week after E3 and you're very
tired so definitely no rooms I have to
go somewhere else yeah directions to the
First National Grocery Store and I'm
busy I don't know stop your ping me with
questions wow wow you just lost a star
sir only four
left yeah do so do y reviews start at
five and go
down as we're talking about reviews sure
you haven't seen it every Hotel starts
off as a perfect
five yeah every Chef starts with three
Michelin
stars until you [__] up your first eggs
turn over and then he what's
up excuse me good call
subtitles see if they have
them
no yep
bam something tells me we're going to
need them as well but these Jack
Walters uh robes alien robes what do you
want could you help out a stranger to
this fine Port are you being funny no
not at all you are talking like kind of
a d to the first national I hear they
have a store in town inou don't take too
Kylie to live from out of town get lost
stranger you should have just said
where's the grocery store yeah what did
these people are just unnecessarily unh
oh there it is [__] you it's right I
should have just looked should looked
around this tiny bustling Square hello I
need to buy some granola bars I'm
feeling very peckish I also need water
I'm
dehydrated this is annoying they put
some sort of impenetrable force field
around oh
hello be cautious when sneaking past
enemies to avoid detection keeping cover
whenever possible well I mean there's no
consequences right what could possibly
be the consequence of running right up
to that guy you want to do it we need we
need to do a science Danny come on just
get up in his
face hey what's up it's
unlocked
whoa you can't come down here the cons
is am I going to reload outside wow is
he dead or Undead sorry Constable he's
at least very Haggard snooping around I
need to be more careful
tiptoe he has not been eating right it
won't open or like doing good hygiene
for many years it's cuz the grocery
store's
closed seriously this place is a food
desert food desert they're just left to
scr whatever they can from barrels and
like slurp fish from dark caves that's
why they all look like
G should I I think I should hide
here that looks like a pretty shadowy
spot right yeah this game's got mad
Shadow physics can you use your Arkham
Vision whoa oh oh sticky keys sticky ke
God damn it godamn it Windows did you
want to turn on sticky keys are you sure
wait press shift five times again it's
not how it works God damn I swear to God
how get stick keys he doesn't know got
sticky keys you press shift five times
do you actually you know oh God damn it
oh no c main win 32. exe production crew
claps ingest do you reckon do you reckon
this game has quick saves I bet it does
I bet it doesn't I bet it doesn't oh
you're going to be back at the oo a time
before quick
saves oh the horror the terror please
don't take me back there can I we switch
over the next game too we could we could
just swap to the next game
and no one will have thought this
G yeah zenx media take that this was the
original Fallout 3 who I'm in all of a
sudden God damn it take that yeah that's
why all these people look mutated
that explains a lot actually they look
like ghouls from the capital Wasteland
oh you son of a [__] you son of a [__]
video game yeah you're in the hallway
going put us back in the [__] oh no
continue hit
continue yeah come on come on put me
outside visit you're listen guys any
sane mind must reject such a fantastic
idea inth am I back in the
bus yeah you're in the bus God damn it
oh it's fine I mean the bus is going to
end this
it's going to end in like two minutes we
don't even have to go into the hotel we
can just run straight over to the to the
grocery
store is this Todd Howard joint or is
this like the other it's also a scathing
indictment of America's immigration Poli
in the early
Century what in insouth they
keep see this whole conversation is
about
International this was a isolationism
this was Todd how's passion project he
never really his political diet tribe
this is his Ken LaVine
movement kind a b his heart was never in
that whole Elder Scrolls thing this is
the game he always wanted to make Mom
when I grow up I'm going to make a game
about about inbred Port people and Squid
beasts end the I might play this
actually now I know it's Bethesda game
really cuz they have great like World
building stuff this is a great world
except for the doors
yeah see you unhe helpful
dick it's probably a good game it is a
good
game Dan he likes it and also was
terrified by it as a youth here we go
here we go I'm going to speedrun it whoa
what's up
Constable you going to Bunny Hop your
way past this Constable straight down
Federal
Street God you crawl really slow like
that I got
it get low
move slow well you're telling me is not
to tap shift five times five times could
I could I go in there do you think
there's a jum oh you can go one what
about those two barrels you go in that
Corridor what's in here probably more
people
though can I lean no can lean that way
oh you can lean got that
lean Qui get around the corner get it
get into the Shadows here we go that was
close that was some that was some MLG
dark
cornering I turned
Pro and it's unlocked yes it
is Andy chat's asking about your Subaru
oh it's
good thanks
Chad oh scratch marks this is one of the
many sweet mechanics in this video game
yeah I'll be all like you want to come
get me cop you try just give me a second
it takes a minute this thing's very
heavy makes so much noise please ignore
the loud noises I'm sure your ears are
clogged from poor hygiene anyways and a
Bola everyone in his Town's got a
Bola what this game was before its time
watch out for medical boxes they contain
treatment needed to patch up injuries
watch out for them that's kind of an
ominous way to direct the player
attention to Medical
boxes is that a medic box it's a medical
box
that sweet medicine can I steal this P
can I just the Tail's empty that's a
shame oh you go straight for the
money what's this run
down oh
hello clipping looks like the door was
forced open and there's scratch marks on
the wood oh I'm going to get Ri [__]
there's a bottle of bootleg rum and a
wooden
handle that is the most adventure gamey
thing to pick up for that
hand a bottle of boot R rum and a wooden
handle I'm just going to grab it the
drawer is empty all right what the what
does the handle
open oh
[__] that oh [__] it's the cops it's the
fuzz what's the hand open What's the
handle open that door it won't
bu looks like I need some sort of got it
looks like you need some I got to stick
the rum in there just pour it in there
and the troll beneath there will get
drunk and let you into his party see why
I why I really want to get out of here
is is that they they will genuinely
knock down those doors and chase you oh
[__] D [__] no way no way no way video
game didn't use a ladder good at all
reload or is it or is that part of the
game that's part of it yeah okay so a
big part of this game is running away
from people and panicking and freaking
out whoever's down there you
rock oh bro broke my favorite
ladder wow you can rot in the grocery
basement I mean that's like the place
he's least likely to rot and nutrients
nothing of Interest I see a medal box
jerk you got to look on the top shelves
man and push that thing back and forth
right yeah yeah ladder action do I use
that to GTFO I do wait what it's very
difficult to see what's going on we're
back on point
can you even jump on
there you could take a running jump at
the
ladder oh just walk up the oh
no I have a very short memory holes in
the bricks what are those holes in the
bricks behind you
where yeah those I can feel the air
through holes in the brick work here huh
oh just run and smash that uh ladder
through there so make a Molotov cocktail
and throw it at the bricks and we just
push this into the wall
incred rate this is as fast as I go I
think it goes the track stops oh oh
yeah didn't see that of
vandalism I cannot believe that
happened listen I was like I'm just
going to you've seen the pop you've got
a stample of the population of in mouth
you think there are like some real
strong masons in that town oh Masons
what are the pictures of man it's a dark
room Sonic sweet buildings yeah
conspiracy M Mason the JFK
assassinations all of them's oh look
they have some old man pubes
too watch out for ammo pickups I love
how they say they'll be useful in the
next chapter they're like you ain't
getting a gun [__] hold on to
that that's called
foreshadowing oh oh [__] mommy holy [__]
Sprint directly here this new broad must
have kicked new
Broad New broad nothing of Interest God
this guy Su nothing of Interest here
except that noo
broad it's been weeks since I've SE why
broad noo
herself guess I'll have to do some
investig you know what's better than a
normal Broad New broad I can unbolt this
door yeah action that door oh loading
screen
NOP can drive out of here and never come
back and be
sane hello hello Jack suspicious
stranger I know you Lucas macki sorry to
startle you in Smith doesn't get a lot
of visitors new name spread fast not
yours what are you doing in town Jack he
about the missing burnam boy not bad I'm
a private detective my client's a friend
of the
burnhams seen the latest press from
Arkham what was that boy's been quite
busy a strong Breeze some sort of press
release what about you Mackie you're
obviously not a local what's your you
don't
look you don't look fa all jacked up
nothing too exciting I'm sorry CU in
Brad as everyone else I'm a government
Factory inspector it's almost like your
parents wen't cousins you could come
from
aers speaking of which I bet your toes
aren't webbed or anything Jacob I mean
it's so both of your eyes are pointing
in the same direction you don't look
like around here your tongue's not four
times too big friendly you seen in this
damn town but I've been in this business
long enough to know he's hiding
something sure the business of this guy
sure is a detective the business of
noosing
broads H all right should
I was that it this is back in the
grocery store there so you're yeah
speaking of Boy Scouts oh you're having
a vision real
quick there's one time at Boy Scout camp
what the hell where we were doing knots
and someone showed us how to do like a
noose and then it became everyone's
favorite knot you were doing I learn how
to tie new boy scouts yeah hey what's up
no and theying us it was at soccer camp
Oh yeah and then there someone was like
if you do more than like 12 rolls it's
illegal or something oh yeah yeah yeah
that's such you need at least 13 for it
to not come unraveled so it really
snapped in neck yeah like that same
experience it grew up like 2,000 miles
away from
you my name's Jack Walters and my boy
scout experience was way worse don't sir
oh really Cub Scouts was the bomb Boy
Scout tro no total
disorganization just shab situation
sorry man I'd not rightly know that for
sure all habits cleaning rooms are thems
from out of town can leave a man I
learned how
to me old habit is that the broad that's
any ropes I can just tie noes over here
an extension cord will also do I don't
think I remember I think I can do it I
think I
could not sure I guess I better go
somewhere else I remember it being
pretty easy actually I'm looking for a
young lad called Brian Burnham he worked
in the first national I'm a friend of
the family I heard the listen Joe
Sergeant only knows about two things
driving a bus and living in a dirty
chimney he ain't doing B Burnham doesn't
do either it's not Bo Burnham it's not a
comedian or something Bo Burnham that's
not YouTuber we turned into a comedian
it's Bo Dallas the WWE Superstar
okay know
the with the thing yeah maybe no but I
think Bo Burna might be the developer of
Samurai gun actually
Bo I'm going to look that up cuz it's
important should we just walk the [__]
out of here it won't open I'm you don't
just walk out of enouth out of this town
you got to take the bus out it won't
budge yo video game where do you want me
to go mini map a no mini
map nobody knows this oh here we go
Washington Street this looks cool can we
start a series called cthulu mods of the
week oh [__] look at this something's
happening and the ship that L
supplies with a good wine piping with
good wind pipe in are you a stereotype
of my Countryman he's just a drunk my
voice he is really like spray got a real
bad penis
situation did someone like what you put
a little like trick tip on it or
something how do you get that it's like
those things you put on your kitchen
faet th sounds is G and world
look come here good looking you
think that fine smell of liquor I say
it's got to be a Speak
Easy I guess this is 1922 is this still
in
prohibition pee on me
sure that part bar can you spare a few
pennies young mister I can give you
something for your generosity
it's it's my fifth PE
technique zadok I think he's Eastern
European just a
young the store he's oh the tan drunks
Spill the
Beans killed what makes you think that
them from out of town running a store
taking business from the order of Deon
order of
isn't that guy Esports
dudeo yeah that Street Fighter
guy order of Dao hargon he's that video
there is famous I think we're real close
to something happening in this game I
don't want to quit this give him some
drinks did you want drinks oh I got
drinks for him yo drunken shut up
talking let me give me this ram my fan
with this crank you got have the crank
as well if you want you can use it to
take dumps or
something old lady Warren's house go and
fetch me a bottle of something to wet
old Z whistle I think your whistle is
wet
enough over whistle there you
go tell me your secrets you just killed
that
man why you're uncomely kind young fell
he'll be a little something it's going
to be
good in your help
me no don't don't just
barf damn give me a key now
barf does it get you into the Billiards
I like I just wanted to soak you and
vomit is that too much to ask
yeah now you be calling me crazy lip
switch rumoring an anchor and lip
switch I really need the subtitles here
I don't have a clue what this man is
saying since before you was
Bor c m Where it All Began 10 desperate
folks they order get better go then
there's no better God than a massive Sea
Beast yeah they give you stuff like skin
conditions they did it were around 46
that many folks in town how would you
diagnose the citizens
of I think eczema is the least of their
problems in minutes
you have any of you people been to North
Africa
recently or
Dallas North Dallas next
day of his father's I don't care what
was the key for would you shut up I got
to listen to your [__] story come
on I don't trust anything this man says
he's made it all up Ino Veritas bro
drunk speaks in wine there is truth a
the drunk speaks the truth
carp so
fact was a Massac the jail thrown open
MS of the dead now I just want him to
shut up get you telling me all your
secrets you
stupider come morning this was very
Vivid to Young Danny oire wasn't
it charge this at 11:00 at night when I
was 13 you were having you were
maximizing your kadulu
experience pretty yeah it's pretty
atmospheric
though the people who made who did all
this
Oblivion said the old Captain was now
maybe
maybe maybe this is the team who made W
that game was fun oh yeah you like w I
did w is Chris waters's
snow whoa I wouldn't say I'm super
passionate about wet what the hell are
these potential this guy is he's had a
good time with it he likes wet in and
wet out whoa you just God this is no
putting this guy down if you got any
more room I'll tell you another 20 lines
of exposition just stand over you want
me to pee on you is that what's
happening now I'll pee on you if you
want you don't need to tell me any
secrets key to the town house it could
come in hand what's a poor house I think
it's pretty self-explanatory to is it
where people live yeah okay it's well
with bootle all right I'm going to the P
we should probably go play Silent H but
any oh [__] hey you look way too Mr
Walters I must speak with you you not
minutes that's what I like about this
game it sounds like almost like me my
name's Rebecca Lawrence and unless you
want to join en's long list of missing I
urge you to follow me people missing
missing huh like Burnham she doesn't
look like she's been buying her car not
sure you or the result of buying cin
daughter Ruth she was dating Brian what
who's Ruth just go with Lady jawline
follow me it's not wise to be seen
talking to Outsiders you're not an
outsider aren't you both
Outsiders oh Rebecca you're mysterious
Jack is a strange place there are things
that have no she's Christian look she
got a crosses
yeah pie trust me I'm good with strange
I don't know good with familiar with
let's say that I think yeah last time it
sent overell it Jack sent you to the for
six years it seems to off
theual elements and ins hey I drew that
on my notebook in fifth
grade they called my
parents moment you can use it you can
use it yes all caps I got to use this
with the use Sy somewhere before but
never surrounded by a star I know is it
another save thing [__] it is all right
we'll save this for the ongoing live
stream you guys want to back out cuz I
feel like we're we're just on the cusp
of stuff happening we need like one
scare we need one scare what didn't we
wasn't the Noose wasn't that no broad
enough of a scare for you so close so
close uh-oh here come some goons here's
some those goons are coming after you
man new those goons it's the Scarecrow
you're going to get noed by some goons G
to get gooned noose that goon where
should I go down here noose yourself a
goon I brought her a goon goon goon oh
hey what's up remember me hey I know
you're not supposed to be seing with me
but what's up fck you're cool like no
we're not we're not talking where' you
say the poor house was again down by the
docks maybe this reminds me of
pathologic oh this is yeah the factory
guys at the March Place doing the tour
guys I hit to burst your bubble but
Bethesda didn't make this just it
yeah know so Andy's got all red up is
this Paul
chaloner is this Paul
chaloner is that red ey that kind of
looks like red eye Esports commentator
red
ey you guys should Google red ey
somebody in the production Booth bottom
teeth look like a
comb my
time look at his teeth man what's
happens when you brush your teeth with
bat Sals for 20 years D let's switch
this game we've been playing for like an
hour no yes do you want to is it you
don't want to the chat uh it's me also
me cuz I also can't play this live
stream for three
hours this Mackie character knows plenty
give me five minutes you said 5 minutes
20 minutes minutes and scare Andy wants
to scare Andy's with me here we go look
at that sweet blur on those L you're not
going to get a scared just on the street
filter on your face you got to wait for
the scare that's what makes it
scary and then it goes waiting the
waiting it's the anticipation sorry I
forgot it's all about waiting that's why
they have all those really boring bits
in Alien Isolation that are really
tedious it's called painting yeah oh
where's the PO house it's definitely in
the center of town
yeah is it that way I don't know read
the signs one of them probably says
poror house no what as he's fine
gentlemen por house was like 1920s lingo
por house
won't open it's locked it must lead to
the back of that guy was incredibly UNH
helpful last time that was the variety
store it won't budge the variety store
sells everything that the other stores
don't sell look at that statue see what
he has to say about it it's headless The
Headless Kabob Crane or no it's the
other guy crane the other guy The
Headless hor from clay figh 2o oh is
this the poor house this looks kind of
poor yeah isn't IAB crane how poor this
one looks won't
open stop just go this is terrible look
how look how poor this place looks
you're down you're just in the
door damn it all right the poor house
would probably have a scare if you
managed to find
it ah I'm scared of how long I'm going
to have to wait for this get
scary might be in here this is the
grocery store back in their grocery
might be in this way oh my God this is
back to the grocery store Zone you're
failing let's F get in the car you're in
the grocery nothing scary
all right chat long until
chat backtracking in the grocery Zone
[__] game there you go call of cthulu
dark corner of the earth something tells
me there's going to be another game
that's even less scary than this at the
end of the show oh is it called yeah but
we'll get to that later is it called
first encounter it's called first
encounter assault Recon
Online what is the online I'm sorry I
picked I should have played the first
level before we started I'm sorry Danny
I'm going to when when this is over and
the stream's done I'm going to keep
playing hey you apologize for nothing
Dann that was neat that was a neat game
to look at thank thank you what was what
was the word you said talking smack
casting dispersions don't cast
dispersions on your own game yeah we
we'll get to um s until 2 in a second
yeah actually I need production to help
because we got to plug this into the PS3
to get the controller to work for a
second there you go for a second while
we wait for that some news this week oh
from the good people at micro games um
Microsoft they've announced micro proos
have announced that they will be
dropping the price of their proprietary
micros games console at the Xbox One
there you go
tight uh yeah post haste uh to what from
what how does how much does it even cost
to do a video game these days they're
popping off 50 bucks from the price of I
think all the SKS is that right yeah so
it's the ones with connect without
connect even if you want to connect it's
50 less so Call of Duty one uh the uh
Sunset Overdrive one which we are giving
away on the show right now at tiny.com
sunsetoverdrive sweep stakes and the uh
the Phil Spencer one you can buy him for
Less yeah so only 50 still very pricey H
how do you guys feel about this who owns
an Xbox One put your hand up all right I
take the one I own games and I take the
one home from work but I don't own one
yet myself can I put my hand down uh
yeah so I was already think uh like
going to buy a Wii U this holiday and
hopefully maybe pick up an Xbox One
there's loads of wi there's loads of um
yeah Bay is like the one that kind of
pushed me over there's a bunch of games
there's enough games that I want to play
game mass for you the Wii U there's not
that killer the X bone reached that
point look at what's coming at this
winter kind of looks like there's more I
don't know what's what's PS4 exclusives
are there coming out over the next
couple of months what PS no the question
is what Xbox One exclusives are going to
get you to get the Xbox Sunset over
drive great game fors of Horizon 2 go I
still haven't played pegle two the
sequel to P there can't I'm pretty sure
you can play that on iPad now P to yeah
I don't know no I think it's still I
don't on iPad either but anyway Peter
yep you have you don't own an Xbox one
no you going to get one no why not don't
want one you don't want one regardless
of price like if someone were like hey
here's an Xbox one you'd be like n don't
want it uh no I'd take one for free but
what what come on I don't I don't make a
lot of money what are we going to do do
you know how much money it cost to fly
cross country right now it's going to
cost me like $1,000 to go see my parents
for Christmas dude you can't fly time
like that's terrible you think I got
money for consoles the r but come on now
now it's 50 bucks less yeah well there's
also big difference there's also a
promotion going on yeah if I get rid of
my stuff you want to trade in your old
console your Xbox 360 to the Microsoft
store SO trading a console that I have a
lot of games for and love do you have
two to spend more money on a console
that has maybe one game I want to play
well I mean whatever I have a like that
deal that whole doesn't work for you
it's trade in an Xbox 360 or a PS3 uh
and you get1 off the sticker price is no
no no so that's that's a separate deal
this deal is only okay the deal I'm
talking about is Microsoft Store only or
online microsoft.com or whatever trade
in a 360 trade in a 360 yeah work it has
to be working operational you get a 100
bucks on and a PlayStation 3 as well or
yeah so what I said is true for the
Microsoft store can you TR PS3 to the
it's towards towards a PS4 you get $125
credit for a gab PS3 or a some odd
gigabyte Xbox so the separate deal there
two deals happening separ consle at
GameStop yeah is you trade in uh what
Peter said yeah either only goes to a
PS4 yeah either way though like nobody's
going to do that right so it's late
October I would in November I would
never do I've got so many games on we're
hitting release season there's there's
like a it's not launch year so there's
been a year and this is like the year
after launch is like always way more
robust with game releases right so it's
a pretty robust year for game releases a
lot of them are
multiplatform uh this is like the first
deal we're sort of seeing in the holiday
season around console stuff obviously
there's going to be more right there's
going to be some Black Friday deals
there'll be some Amazon deals etc etc do
you think it's this is a good time to
take advantage of this deal if you want
to upgrade to an nextg system or should
you wait three weeks and see what
happens I don't think it's going to get
any cheaper than this and the other
thing as well is like if if it's if it's
like folks that haven't gotten any new
console at this stage then they're also
like people who are interested to play
Titanfall and watch dogs and like any
other which you can play on Old you can
play on the old consoles yeah but you
know yes if you yeah but like you
wouldn't if you were W you would if you
were poor perhaps like I don't think
four but just don't want to spend the
money like 500 is a lot of money to
spend on one of those consoles because
what do you get yeah you get some game
you get some okay games you get some
it's I would you know if you really want
to play fors I like I did yeah then you
buy it um it's way better this year than
yeah so like this holiday now they
dropped the price 50 bucks it's like oh
yeah and if you're if which essentially
what like a free game if you're a parent
like uh like T ex controller uh no Tay's
not really a parent
but if if your kid's like I want a new
console I want a new console and you see
one that's $50 less plus comes with a
game kids make that decision that's
awesome well so is that that's who you
think you're you're going going for is
the people who are like all right this
is the year I'm gonna I'm gonna go next
gen if they're bratty kids I'm going to
pick to pick up PS4 or an Xbox one which
one's looking more appealing Xbox One
with a whole bunch of bundles of games
that are hotly anticipated or you know
promoted at the very least uh you know
that strong call duty one is going to
fly off the sh that's going to be gone
straight away well so that one so ugly
but the Call of Duty one is still 400 or
whatever because it has a ter by a hard
drive like I'm not sure how much the 50
bucks really matters I know it'll
probably have for like yeah folks who
are getting them for kids and stuff but
like what percentage of video game
players is that anymore like there kids
don't you know I feel like I'd love to
see the demographic for that sort of
stuff because it seems like consoles are
selling to people in their like mid 20s
and all the kids are playing Minecraft
and then tablet games and free to playay
like 250 right now you can get a 360
that comes with Ghosts Call of Duty
ghosts and Black Ops 2 right so if we're
talking about people going to the store
who just want to get their kids
something yeah I guess they're like holy
[__] this is even $100 less I get
another game parents aren't going to
give a [__] if they're deciding over
value whether or not the game is new I
don't think it's for kids for kids they
probably already have 360 at that point
so they're going to buy their kids games
for the 360 no but but their kids
probably like I wanted the new one and
they're like too bad yeah piece of [__]
you know what they should do is give
them a PlayStation 2 so they can play
all these classic goddamn video games
yeah silent till to this is your scary
game of choice yeah I you know what I've
only played a little bit of this game
but I've heard amazing things about it
so I decided I'd choose it I own it I
just haven't played a whole lot of it
wait have you generally not played much
of solil 2 yeah oh really oh really what
about the first one yeah yeah yeah I
played a bunch of the first one that
also came out in like 1998 or 99 yo what
Action level do you want I want Riddle
level do you want normal Norm core baby
Riddler just are we is this a thematic
inclusion of Arkham is that what's
Happening Here we need a definitely it
all comes back to AR baby there a lot of
subtle noises in this game yeah let's
get let's get that remote control out
here now that's a face does he have
eyeball oh he's do this this face off
have eyeballs he just took his face off
which one of them is John Travolta deep
breath
fart there's a great like oh urinal cam
yes yeah got something urin yo homies
can we get that remote
control thank
you who is the creeper crouching down by
you have to go to the settings TV you
have to go to the settings and play Play
Station
subtitles do you guys want me to pop in
the settings and change the audio
settings real quick hey D are you bad at
catching things you good when there's a
bright light FL at me okay all right
Danny entertain the kids I'm G to back
out not good it's cool we got to do set
I got to change the audio Yeah you need
the audio changing audio Yeah do it I
just don't we don't need to babysit have
you guys played silent Silent Hills any
first one yeah get the cop me that movie
was all right the movie yeah I didn't
mind that movie
what when you say that movie was all
right I didn't mind that under what
circumstances would you recommend
someone watching I thought it was a good
movie it was [__] weird that ending
is super weird it's like super bloody
triangle face Pyramid Head triangle face
Pyramid Head pulls off some skin when
they went to nextg they went plug this
in one more time used to be pyramid used
to be triangle face then they got
threedimensional graphics and became
pyramid in the European version he was
always called triangle face I don't know
I know what to tell you you guys in one
more time is that true no I always you
could have said yes and I probably would
have believed I always love going to
events and seeing people who cosplayed
his uh pyramid yeah cuz it's always like
it looks like the worst because they're
always flanked by sexy nurses doing all
this doing weird poses triangle face for
Halloween do you see that movie Andy no
never Sean Bean's in it does he die uh
no what's his time to death oh no I
think he's the only person who does
actually who breaking I think everyone
else in that movie does oh yeah take us
back to the dirty
bathroom that's Danny's dirty bathroom
face that's my oh back yep I really need
to clean this
bathroom a special eyes I like how he
did one real firm comb down the back of
his head do you like my John Cena
impression you can't see
me do do you guys know this guy's name
if you do don't answer sha Bean all
right what's your guess as to what this
guy's name is I forget no I don't care
if you remember or forget I Ethan Carter
oh you just want to guess Zachary yeah I
just want to hear you guess
uh Kennedy Steve he could be a
chat feel like he's more of a Steve
could be a Mary Mary are you in this
town is this you no she's
not okay first things first wash your
hands bro hold on yeah see interactive
toilet hold on tank
control what just happen oh do you want
me to do it again yeah could you dump
that again I want you to do it four
times in a row that's how the cheat
Works what was that pooping in that's
his that's his I'm about to run stance
PR the right button ready
go
oh I gotta poop I gotta poop I gotta
poop fault oh no I might have just did a
little bit gotta get Gotta
Go San Francisco Carl's rolling
in all Carl he just Lake look at that
backdrop man that's a Sky Box did did
Bungie make this game gorgeous epic Sky
Box that's a photo that's like a Allan
Wake I see this is photo
gramy this is creepy as seen in a hot
episode of reality
check this a very Twin Peaks
moment people going to start speaking
backwards don't we me talk about the end
of that show are we meant to believe
that this dude
parked had a [__] so bad that he jumped
out of his car did not close the door
and ran into that dire restroom and just
it was pristine when he went in there
yeah I got a I got a letter name on
EnV Mary I wonder who it was from or to
my wife's name
oh it's ridiculous it's a ridiculous
name couldn't possibly be
true this voice acting reminds me I
forgot to tell you that the voice acting
in dark Corners called Gulu was
bad Jack Walters was real wooden di that
the voice acting the eyes my ability to
play it without crashing
it my ability to prepare a
demo all right we're get we're we're
snowballing out of control here let's
get back on point what does ghost Mary
think about our special place riddles
man by the time I realized something was
wrong the entire s and ta was infested
with
zomers we spent the whole day there
well I feel like I'm spending the whole
day here staring at the water okay
coming from someone who played for an
hour something scary happened was that
actually an hourz it was like 50 minutes
wow Mary really be there try this hat
on right that's what we' made people do
for the sweep Stakes to win an Xbox One
a you saying that's the Hat of what's it
called theing hat Sorting Hat come on
Danny Jesus it's like You' never I
wonder if it wants me to look in the car
been to Harry Potter land in
Orlando it's my one regret from when we
went to Orlando yeah we didn't really
live properly you got a map of salent
right I did try and find the poor house
my game didn't have a fraking map the
observation deck didn't have a map or
any who was help you could not make a
game today with a without a map and a
town full of people who didn't want to
help look at this
[__] sorry I'm not doing that any I
thought I was done you guys don't get to
see that anymore a
is that the that's the equivalent of the
door opening in Resident Evil yeah all
right love the elbows so long since I
played this look at his elbows at that
dead Sprint there he gets tired though
he'll start to slow down really you have
to like let him pant for a second yeah
see now he's slowing you know is Mary
the fog see what we're missing right
here is there are these like footsteps
that are like in the distance not even
in the distance like they sound like
they're really close but there's like no
one near you they don't they're not
there the whole time they kind of like
come and go
this game is all about like
psychological
horor can you stop for a
second can perfect stop you yeah right
behind the
tree great
form good form Peter is this fog or is
there a massive fire that was my H
impression this is fog I feel like I
just heard an animal noise yeah there
are some weird
noises are you sure it's just not his
rotator cuffs tearing as he runs like
that with his elbows actually you can
never be too sure when it comes to
rotator cuffs always play at safe kit
I'm going stick my head in here
Timmy this is The Game's like save thing
what is that it's a save point gives me
a weird feeling feels like something's
groping around in my skull oh God it's a
memory card anyway I'm not going to save
get it memories how many blocks do is
your memory
t uh
oh
he just barreled through that elbows and
all I was the one who did that camera so
when you're playing games like this by
yourself right this is this is obviously
meant to be an atmospheric sort of
moment and I'll interrupt if this is
something I'll pause it as long as you
pay attention to Peekaboo what is that
Mary Mary Quite Contrary how does her
garden your graveyard grow oh watch your
hands yeah right Jesus this is not the
place to do that oh
I'm gonna skip this basically she's like
I'm looking for
somebody and then you appear out FR and
ter me too also looking for somebody
observation deck new Step Rod well like
a a section like this obviously you're
jogging through it because we're trying
to see some other stuff in the demo but
like if you guys are playing at home do
you like incline the stick like maybe
not all the way don't press the sprint
button just kind of like deliberately do
your like a slow character walk to sort
of give yourself a little bit more of
that atmosphere I don't I run through a
lot of these games because I'm scared
like this would be a headphone game for
me and also like you walk a little bit
and you're like okay this taking 20
minutes and I've gone like five meters I
need to ha ass yeah yeah I think
eventually on this section I would get
tired of doing that but like maybe if it
was you know a new section a new camera
angle walk a little bit I guess more now
to just sort of appreciate the the
visuals because so many games like this
look really pretty I guess this is a
very pretty game I guess this was a
really track
visually
appealing F resent evil did yeah like
works this is like when I
was super hating on consoles it was I
was like console fog this is like the
epitome of console F but this isn't
console fog though right have you never
played Silent Hill before no so the
first game and this one are just
notorious for the fog and it's used as
like a a tool to kind of keep you
guessing like what's coming it's not
like a technological limitation and it
also help them technologically well it
might have helped them but look at this
his character model is not that
impressive for PS2 it's
whatever that is a pretty crappy camo
jacket they're actually rendering really
far there's actually a one mile draw
distance just put the fog in there that
fog is so deep I mean look at that fog
though that's like it's not just like
bit Maps like that's volumetric I don't
know if it's volumetric but it's it's
decent F having seen fog like Cascade in
especially in this city San Francisco it
like it does have that sort
of it feels like it's all moving in sort
of one Mass but then like if you try to
fix your eye on a certain part of it
it'll evaporate or Another Part will
come will like form and it's like this
this nebulous kind of thing even though
it feels like one entity sometimes it's
pretty
cool
hey unlike this gu's gate someone says
Bruno BRS says I was I'm wrong it was
Technical and and I say prove it because
you could just be saying that show your
work he's just a PC Master race like me
knows the truth where are you are you
running along a dam but but like
seriously look what's rendered here it's
like nothing there's no way that's just
their fault for not taking it about well
all the riddles man take up a lot of
memory oh you're wrong can you run off
this especially when you said it to hard
no did you Deuce off the edge I can dump
off
it all your memory dumps man I Pooch my
butt out at you Cliff okay apparently
the lead designer said so prove
it Source
it link it poop it twist it pull
it poop
it I was not part of Bob non-canonical
hey when you see something call of
cthulu had at least 20 inbred people by
the time we got to this stage that's
true hey you know Danny I believe you
were the one who argued let's start at
the beginning of the game you said no no
question we're going to start at the
beginning of the game shut
up squabbling you guys have already
decided
that I'm just here for the ride got more
about the journey I'm going to get ins
salty cuz you were all [__] on my C
Barker it's more about the journey than
the
inbreds he I mean honestly for all that
this dude runs like a complete goo he is
quite
fit not in the European sense was
someone eating Cherry he has good cardio
oh my God yes well clearly I'm going to
go see what that dude's up to we found
something hey can you give me uh
directions I was in this place called
inbrook earlier and none of those
[__] y know where the grocery
storees at I'm I never heard of no
grocery
store I'm looking for a missing boy
excuse excuse me Madam hobble legs I
didn't hear I didn't knew snow
bro no just follow the gem is this like
the Lost Woods where you're just going
to keep run until you like take the
right sequence of turns you're just
going to keep running through a foggy
town no I'm getting
there don't you
worry
you did get a
map watch your speed here is that why
you're is that why you weren't running
it said watch speed on the fence yeah
I'm a cautious
bird you take damage for hitting the
thing yes it's
electrified oh it's
bar look like a good place to
go Mary is that
you is that a person what did you just
pick up out of that did he not see the
person no it doesn't see the person
thing oh it's
freaky oh there you go oh gross it's
like a flesh bag head that's what
happens when you keep banging your
cousins for like an extra 50 years it's
just misunderstood you that's the end
game sweet ass it's a good good bud
must been a dancer before for glutes and
nothing else he's like
nope I now have a tiny breakable piece
of
wood oh god oh it's the worst got this
oh yeah that would be a pretty easy
Halloween costume is it dead just need a
lot of Saran Wrap and
jam but You' have to have a really nice
this move you would have to have a
really tone some tone glutes to pull it
off otherwise it would be like you look
like oh from Silent Hill too right oh
turn around let me see it because they'd
expect like a
molded fine buttock Apple
Bottom to see if I can't get us to the
scary house as Qui as
possible there man pubes all over the
place appear out of
nowhere you're going to be picking as M
PE out your teeth for the next couple
days Jam see Jam I spilled it Jam better
take it anyway I might need it conserve
better take it anyway all right consult
the map boys where you supposed to
go trying to get my goodness look at all
these places down here to sa Street oh
come on go to big Jay's go to Sal Street
my friend Happy Burger happy Burger
gonzale Gonzalez Gonzalez Mexican
restaurant oh you got jam on your feet
you got all that jam it's cool just like
smash random flesh bag people things
he's holding that stick with
intent run around
town come on pick up
speed what did you say pick up speed
needs momentum pick up speed do speed
that's how this game started it's like
a adventure game for sure oh
[__] oh oh did it just spew
sure tried
to you took evasive action
though going kill it he just like Ain
got no business talking to that gentlem
got pick up save your energ take a
little spew
bath oh where was it coming out of did
not look like it was coming out of the
head or neck area where I at yeah
Gonzalez go to Gonzalez get that burrito
get up happy burger oh that reminds me
of the burrito I just go just go into
Happy burger and eat a bunch of burgers
so that your character model gets gets
fatter your character model
gets all new game mechanics should be
retroactively added to all games
forever every game would then be a 10
out of 10 yep everything would be
wonderful we played that sweet
homogeneous
world we played that uh San Andreas HD
version that came out on 360 during
extra
life was it HD it was was it HD HD H did
you get your H's worth my
H's where you going trying to go ha a
ppy with it go to this car it has a key
in it or it tells me to go to some place
to meet a guy did you read a f no I
played this morning did you read a game
FAQ on this
this damn where can find game damn oh no
I game fq where can they find a game FAQ
Chris they were looking for for all your
FAQ needs Vis games go to game FAQs Biz
where is
that
yep game chats. ip.com
hell sweet Wago oh yeah go into that
thing it's like you're walking on that
street in Berkeley that doesn't really
have a lot of houses walk through like a
semi-industrial area there's just hell
of are we going to barell
Nell's bar or
nees listen a lot of people like to go
to nees because they have two for one
drink specials on Tuesdays but for my
money it's big Jays all the way oops
you've always been a fan of big Jays I
don't have any health questions yet [__]
why didn't you pick up that Red Envelope
if you were paying attention You' have
learned that that is a safe Point yeah
come on man don't you remember the well
what about the target thing I thought
the I thought there was just Wells
everywhere oh what's the note on the
couch I already read that if you were
paying attention you
I was paying attention before but not
one minute ago it said please clean my
Winnebago love Dale we are out of fear
see you at nees come find me so did
those red squiggles appear because you
like investigated that area yeah and
it's like n son you can't go that way
and so then it puts it on the map
because you've discovered that n son you
can't go that way yes what are all these
weird ass things lurching around you
know what I'm going to kill one just so
you guys can see what it does after you
kill it oh gross oh that definitely now
sweet
boots SC all over you does have some
serious boots ready here it goes what no
way after it that's cool don't let it
get away no it's not
done
oh weird that was Del the flashlight Mr
Booze asks so what are you supposed to
do in this game besides running
around
um find stuff solve a mystery figure out
why you're dead wife wrote you a letter
riddles disobey traffic signage NE is on
neie Street that's how popular this
baring true yeah all right definitely
going inside nothing bad could happen
that was the same door opening sound as
Rainbow
6 ding Chavez knows how to open the door
in this game
Alpha go what's that symbol at the end
of Martin
Street it's a it's liter it was
literally a question
mark what is that may I don't understand
it's like a c with a tail on it oh I
think that's where I get the key to the
apartment building I think is this like
that's not the Woodside apartment yeah
mhm I got to get that
key what's it say there was a two for
one happy hour starts 3:00 tell your
friend I got to
go where's the
hellmouth was there ever a good Buffy
game what good Buffy game was there ever
a buffy game chaos B yeah there was
chaos bleeds really for like the uh
Xbox that one was all
right Chris follow your Buffy knowledge
I don't know if there was another
one those things are idiots there
probably was another one probably at
least two and Chaos BL are pretty all
right as I
recall believe the indust street believe
it there's a key on a dead person look
for a strange symbol y'all want to see
your dead body yeah yeah yeah I'll go to
the woods going to be one of those one
that skitters along the street cuz in
that case
no oh wait are you the dead body I was
looking for you are
absolutely yeah I did hit him with see
to the apartment
oh that was great what was
it we'll never
know oh man you did go to the if you did
go to your Halloween party Dr as that
thing you got you get really drunk and
then you just skitter along the
floor
yeah
greatus any shouts in the chat for you
for the spray attack though you have to
learn how to you you did a pist thing
nice any shats in the chat for your
favorite horror
games lot of chat about we're thinking
about any ver predator for this one
jumpy scare I prefer creepy you prefer
creepy yeah it doesn't come across on
these things but you know whatever I me
this kind of has this kind of is both
right give it true give it like 5
minutes well it'll be it'll be creepier
once I get what I said cthulu yeah but I
but I've played this game in the past 24
hours so yo can you push a bookcase in
front of the door so that the drunken
skitter things can't come at
you all right definitely go to an
apartment complex dude I've got my plank
I love you have gory and horror movies
and all that I'm like I came up with
that stuff but you know horror games I
didn't never find compelling you
scary amnesia
super scary condemned but the but super
scary I started yeah condemn was pretty
condemn is pretty [__] scary Amnesia
I just kind of stop playing because it's
kind of boring use that yeah just real
like it takes a while to get scary did
you just drink that yep it looked like
Sriracha or like nasty quick that's
who's going to spit in their faces if
they come after
him all the people are like this because
they don't like this is how I'm going to
maneuver through hallway now just run
into a wall just run into wall turn and
then just keep running straight until I
get to another wall with my elbows out
like
this and Doom 3 scared the crap out of
ke in 93 when he came out but he was
born in 93 so that means Doom 3 came out
and want 2004 so he was n 11 years old
when I came out yeah Rob was talking
about that earlier oh yeah Doom 3 is
cool it's pretty startling with points
yeah lost on the last DLC whistleblower
we need to go down
here get scared and then go back resi
one was pretty oh gross it was one of
the gross things you don't like scary
games D Chris you I don't no uh or scary
movies like I could do alien caliber oh
that's kind of a weird shot what what's
a scary movie to you though like oh like
horror movies like oh jeez what the
she's like all legs
oh peace I'm out of
here like horror stuff like when I was a
kid like I don't know even the ads for
like Chucky yeah that would freak me out
yeah like that kind of like slasher
horror stuff I just have no interest in
stuff that's like Thriller that like
there's some there's something more
intriguing going on I can kind of deal
with but even then like I don't know I
just it gets into my imagination and
into my like then I think about it when
I go to bed and dream about it and
messes with me and I don't like it what
about like something like a vent Horizon
which is like I watched that one yeah
yeah I enjoyed that cuz that's that's
pretty scary yeah parts that's like yeah
yeah that that one I was okay with I
mean I don't know I I guess it's like
movies
where the the point isn't the scare it's
like the the scare is part of it but
there's also like some other story or
some other thing going on but if the
point is just just like let's see what
kind of [__] up [__] we can put into a
movie and then throw it at your face
yeah no I'm not got got taken to a level
that's pretty dumb even before it got it
went full Gorno like I was just not into
it when I looked at this this morning it
was like 3:15 or something that is way
too early to be awake Peter so something
about a sleeping problem your order of
operations determines that clock really
also it says words but I don't know why
push it are there scrap scrapes on the
ground poop on no you can't push this
guy yeah so like Resident Evil I forced
myself to play through that one freaked
me out it was the fixed camera angles
mostly that like did it I had to return
that game when I was a kid I got it like
right when it came out too much couldn't
handle it I played with a friend and he
owned it and I was like cool I like this
game and I tried to play it by myself at
night one day and I was like nope nope
nope going back to the store I was right
okay until I got to the hunters and I
literally stopped like I just gotten
confident killing zombies like I'm okay
I'm okay now and they like cuz yeah they
don't like tell you that's coming or
then that first guy takes your head off
and you're like [__] this you're like
click click click thing like no no done
I got I killed the first one I think and
I stopped I I never completed a pass
there oh really there's going to be a
leg monster down here I mean I was an
adult when I finished that one like I
did not play that as a kid nope oh got
that remake coming
remake remake remake got to me as a kid
fantasmagoria wow you played that yeah
why like why was I playing that that
game has some pretty messed up stuff in
it oh yeah that was the first game with
like sexual assault in it I think see I
don't remember that yeah there was the
first game was sexual assault was
Custer's
Revenge oh yes where you basically rape
a Native American woman yeah that's true
was before that
noers was like AAR 2600 right yeah yeah
do the skitter does it
God can it injure you while skittering
it just did but I can also injure it
while skittering is he is it a stun God
damn
it it's like a spider you just want to
die that thing is super
creepy like I'm not getting creeped out
in any way by this right now I want to
clarify I mean this is like obviously
not a setting that's conducive to
getting creeped out uh but you know like
I haven't played uh much I've watched
people play Dead Space
little but I haven't played that one
that one's tough for me too cuz it's
like so obviously this incredible
achievement in terms of like sound
design and visual design and pacing and
mechanics like hearing people talk about
that game sounds so awesome but you know
you got to draw the line somewhere for
yourself personally it is and I think oh
yeah
no yeah I think that's I think I was
right on the cusp with that one yeah and
I felt really uncom for the first half
of dead space one and it kind of got
used to it and then Dead Space 2's intro
was just like like oh yeah I remember
how be scared oh Jesus Christ leg
things hit it in the vagina oh God
that's which
one oh that's I don't like how it get
that was good it can go either way it
can just turn
around come at yeah never stop killing
that until your animation
stops until the big until the large
blood pool starts hang out in this
closet should we hang out in this closet
and then play the scariest game of the
day yeah we can switch whenever you guys
want to cuz I know you're scared that's
I'm scared I'm scared
of of of having to wait any longer to
play this next game oh no uh but yeah to
remind folks we are we're giving away um
a Xbox One with a Sunset Overdrive the
scariest first party exclusive second
party exclusive you could think think of
oo ch.com Sunset Overdrive sweep stakes
will'll be announcing the winner at the
end of the show in fact though you the
game you get a shiny white xbone and the
controller that's also white yeah and
the video game whose trailer we're going
to
watch right
now so we're going to before this whole
thing started just bloated through life
I know this is going to sound crazy but
my life didn't start until the world
came to an
end I want to be something more
fun K ass
all right nerds this ends now I sense
some epic missions in my future to
battle together we'll take bisco down or
we won't but we'll get some Wicked
respawn animations
time get ready to die
[__] oh
[__] are you
okay and now for a game which originally
was supposed to be the not scariest game
of the the stream but in a Twist of Fai
may actually be the most entertaining
thing we show today it's first encounter
assault Recon Online AKA
FOH I'm a file are you Andy Balman yeah
it's called This is the Animaniacs of
fear oh God get to the game oh okay I
just want to you people in charge of
cameras can you play as uh Alma oh
that's op man can you play as Paxton
fettle you have to you have to uh pay a
lot of real world money to play as Alma
can you play as Alma Wade is Lawrence
Alma Tama Adama do you know who that is
Chris Fe you might be the only person
who knows do you know I don't know but
it seems to stall out Lawrence Alma Tama
he's a painter what do you think about
that try to say for the folks at home
who don't know what the hell this is H
this is the what the free-to-play of
shooter from everyone's favorite first-
person horror game that nobody asked for
yeah that that sums it up there's
nothing else to say hero yeah the
server's still up somebody was asking oh
I see okay why didn't you go for the
second happen though I should probably
restart the game
now everything on this week show is
haunted something hit shift five times
question have you joined a clan now to
fight in Clan Wars no are you now or
have you ever joined a clan to fight in
Clan Wars I'm clanless baby hire me
have you not made the glaive dragons oh
pie of gaming
everybody yeah we're killing this oh
what nice graphics on this are terrible
this game is
haunted Hy didn't want to play this and
I was like you should come on the show
and play this game and he was like nope
and I was like please and he was like
nope and then I said please we did it
and you said please for realsies yeah
and then you said you're on the whole
show you know and he was like cool clear
your schedule from 2 p.m
Pacific odd
infinitum cuz it's FOH time baby f for
everybody if they really wanted to like
stick to their fear acronym thing they
should have made online an acronym like
fear all fear o a r o
n uh Andy what is your operation plan
status have you run out of on operation
plans what is operation plan my
operation plan is to uh prematurely
drain all my Roth IRAs and pump all my
money into this game y so I can be hella
op that is the most scary thing you've
ever said for a few brief Shining
Moments you will truly live my KD will
be off the chain let's not miss the
Warner brotherus thing this time check
it out
games this is the real reason I
restarted yeah they're tiny they're tuny
animia ex oh wait no it's Alma oh it's
set in a resolution that doesn't allow
them to show it that's why they didn't
show it damn in playay baby wow Inplay
interactive it's got Havoc physics
engine here we go choose the second one
this time God look how credited it is
I'm in all right so explain fear for the
folks at home fear fear all fear is a
reaction that humans have when they see
something that threatens fear was a
really sweet game back in the day I
don't know 2004 again maybe 2003 people
know what that is tell them have a fear
online ohline well first click and find
a game and then tell Danny about fear
off let's should we do the tutorial
because I was the most that was the most
fear thing no sure what if you think so
Alo was actually in the tutorial okay no
play the all right Death Match find a
game it's just a death
match who's she I don't know she's your
helpful friendly should we buy some
stuff let's buy some stuff okay is this
pay to win what's going on oh yeah we're
going to I told you I drained all my
accounts and my money into this uh I got
the laser but that's PVE only oh maybe
this is yeah maybe should I equip the
laser what's the money called fear land
is it fear points I don't know it's this
P
Price Paxton the Paxton F Paxton FAL
bucks taxton
bucks uh what other guns are
Tundra come on you're not going to be
sniping people yeah we don't want to
snipe how many ghosts do you usually
kill in a game equip uh well you can
ghost what the hell is that thing oh
this is my this okay so fear's best gun
was the uh stake thrower or like the
bolt thrower this is the bolt thrower
multiplayer so it's pretty cool uh well
as cool as you can get with how do
whatever I don't know do your psionics
oh yeah okay you're going to be kicked
in 3 seconds I
am Jesus Christ that's fine all right
so let's let's get out of your pionic
and ready up a game go back hit back
should I join a clan hit back just shoot
F game oh yeah let's go boom hit ready
immediately go back never show a Sonic I
can't you can't it'll go back see God
damn it
ready just remain ready everyone else
look daytime mansion look at all the
maps there are too bad you are on the
other team from hate Fury of the hate
gaming clan oh what cuz that player
seems like they are pretty good at
F say hi to everyone in your chat they
must have dumped all their money yo you
guys yo you want to do drugs do it type
it in honey
I'm you guys know Halloween soon what no
it's is that why this is happening
wrong look America
eliminat is the threat the
president so it's just a online
shooter what it's so well lit it's
bright daylight outside does this remind
you of fear going through office Parks
it reminds me of the Italy level from
Counter Strike what is FOH about this
okay well there's probably going to be
some scares if I follow the map to like
the dark places you should follow hate
Fury yeah I'll follow hate Fury oh that
door does no it doesn't oh yeah here we
oh no that's where I started there a
dead person there oh yeah
whats I got him this game looks like it
was you got a jar beans you literally
shot a jar of baked
beans oh my God your screen got shot wow
you got Beed that was really good yeah
you got an assist I am shocked you got
an assist you actually land a shot what
the [__] go for a
swim Elma likes the water so maybe
she'll be in here hello in the corner to
the corner there's
a every
map he's shooting us look it's Johnny
Mosley come sorry white let's cut his
hair this game looks real shitty like
just Graphics even look real like this
is like can strike you know it like
works so you can't you can't take a
Michelin star away for that you
know C head shot just AFK grenade see
here's the Bol Sho yeah I'm shooting
bolts all right that's which is rad
because fear is like that the best part
of
fear oh I was doing way better at my
death get I got I got it's cuz the
keyboards covered in cobwebs now these
man these oh man really cramp my game
all right if you had show me this game
play there is no way that I would have
said oh is this this fear online game
why I was saying we should play the
tutorial
because you actually woke up in the
hospital and had to go through some
horror stuff okay we'll do it in a
second and you got 10,000 points to
spend on this gun oh what
yeah it I don't know what I did he got
grenaded he got an assist easy
definitely friend is there any
slowmo yeah I don't know if there's
slow-mo for this multiplayer stuff there
was in the
tutorial look at that lady follow hate
Fury oh there a snowboard again this map
is just a big circle that's a bad guy
right
there Chris I just don't have your
shooter Acumen that table's not going to
stay up how many times you push it up
put it
down it works better when there's not
cobwebs all over it this cobwebs here
better when there cob I'm GNA lock you
into the cobweb
God there we go there we go y Ricky
guitarist asked what for snowed in San
Francisco oh I know that answer uh
extreme esport you do a 360 mute grab
over
Bart what and then you stop the landing
Rick Cod 908 says how is this fear LW
yeah exactly it is pretty much fear L
cuz the stakes I'm shooting or the pegs
or whatever look at that Tron dude look
at that what was with his hip yeah this
doesn't is this an American Embassy is
this like a full from fear that we're
not picking up on this is like rainbow
six's first level if you want if you
want to go back to that yeah what what
what oh that was nice yeah no welcome
back see you later take that Cur on that
dude's a waste what is up with
it it's one of it does the shooter thing
where like they animate the Torso and
the like legs separ
do that's paxt and
FAL you think everyone's Paxton FAL well
in fear everybody
is there are only three characters in
fear Elma p and FAL and the ghosts at
the end of the first game stupid ghosts
are
hard all right show me this tutorial I
don't know if I can come on man he's got
to finish the
match who they're only playing to 100
don't worry my KD is real
hot it's it is a real hot pile of
garbage I about tutorial let's do
tutorial I don't know actually I promis
tutorial I don't know if I can actually
do the Tor now that I've done it I think
the real thing about fear online is
seeing if you can get to the end of the
game without everyone
leaving let me see if I can find like
the go in that look in that chest is
almond in that chest there might be like
a dungeon or something with some fear
elements yeah all right I'm let's try to
find the fuest thing on this map why are
we in this tuskan Embassy what the [__]
is this thing on the map is a portra
barn I bet it's in that Barn is it just
not as bright yeah it's like there's
probably some is it like mild zombies
and stuff yeah that waterfall pool makes
no water sense oh come on I'm going for
that going for that
Barn watch out behind you I got
it yeah you got
something maybe you're all trying to
find out which which one of you is the
real Paxton
fettle yeah there can only be
one all right jibs on the ground go to
the bar at least look at the jibs never
mind going up is that
a oh what that was a head shot come
on see that dude must have bought like
wow all right that was serious is there
jibbing in fear cuz that dude jib real
hard that was like a jib
parkour cuz his torso Flew Over the
Mountain yeah that last that final shot
is really really takes
oh wow Camp come on was there camping in
fear
clearly all right tutorial go out by the
truck I'm going to go to the barn you
guys yeah can you make it to the barn
without getting murder yes back welcome
back welcome back that could not have
sounded more like the Call of Duty
4 uh UAV or oh watch that dude oh my
head came off I don't even get the GL
got shot in it by the AK-47 that
everyone is using in this match why is
the glass shatter maybe because it's
like your goggles guess do you think if
you shot Soul do you think if you shot
in the face oh and it like
Miss would you think you would see your
goggles shatter before you died or would
you die so fast you see it after you
died you die so fast looking at looking
through it and being like dag I'm dead
my goggles is off you wouldn't have time
for your goggles to
shatter Danny your team's only losing by
by 10 kills turn this around all right
we got this Danny Danny the manager dude
Danny's the manager of course there's
mad ha in chat yeah Danny this is your
squad here's the flowchart are you
playing a video game you picked f are
you playing a video game I to the barn
there's mad ha in chat to the barn oh
yeah this is going this is never going
to be an N climax if you're good at oh
it might be the spawn point if you're
good at F get really I'm not impressed
so chat yeah go hide in the corner oh
there go got spawn spawn spawn go back
no you can't he's Invincible for 5
seconds jeez all right
fine
tutorial man you can't go to any dungeon
you're not going to get your fear points
yeah it's almost done a dungeon over
here let's go find out that's going
upstairs back to your
spa probably this is the worst
gameo
bro dude in the
water I'll join you everyone's just
Panic shooting into the water yep
there's no one actually in there that
lady should really put on more not even
wearing any clothes how many fear bucks
do you think that person had to pay a
lot all right we're backing out no wait
it's like the is literally almost over
100 that's it see I told you oh man AR
one oh guys are leveled up level up no
item EX it you get nothing all right
show me this tutorial and then we can
get out of here sweet 3 KD let's see if
I can go to the
tutorial
options I don't think it's an option you
ready yourself you are you're
ready bro there you go bro do you even
game
hi I want to know about crafting go back
oh yeah about
back the guide and the guide oh yeah
learn about the psionic system
no
yes H who want wants to kill themselves
oh when it comes to free-to-play
Shooters hero is one this is really
putting the fear in the competition no
we're going back right yeah
right our Superior games like what
operation
blackl and blacklight retribution yes
that one blacklight retrobution and
literally any other play first person
shooter I could start a new character no
yeah could you start a new Paxton fattal
please can you make your gamertag all
right tutoral here we
go stream Vindicated here it is here it
is everybody soak it in [__]
this is the only bloody stuff you get to
see all day woo what are all these
symbols where did all this GL come from
is it mine oh there she is
where's I got a real bad headache what
is this feeling is it buyer's remorse
well it's free so it doesn't matter no
so no it's not not download
remorse Gigabyte usage remorse walk up
to me oh man we become
one weird press W to walk forward you
have a press a to
[__] good job Soldier drugs give me
drugs go go inside go inside you're
going to need to equip a weapon you know
have a goth queeen hanging out on your
back are you just piggy maing around the
whole place it's like that character
Mortal Kombat X this is this is just a
first person Banjo Kazooie your camera's
[__] all right let's get out here
talking [__] about their camera Tech
yeah that guy fear fear
fear oh
ready fear fear finishing blow allows
you to instantly kill from and many
afterwards like a psychopath why are
they giving you this first person
tutorial and then sing you into a shitty
counter clone yeah oh there she oh you
guys scared she's old yeah I was
terrified you guys scared that was that
was scary you guys
scared object by pressing e pretty squ
oh oh look at stuff's happening how many
times have you have to move objects in
the multiplayer modeer squeezy juice get
some squeezy juice okay no squeezy juice
it's empty
it's they just replaced the texture yeah
you just shot it and it what what do you
think that's all games are
oh oh man she needs your help she's like
I'm your mother or something I think I'm
your crazy mother stop reading her text
I'm your team
mother God you know what I just want to
play fear yeah it has better lighting
than this it's actually legitimately
looks better this is W that's where
peanut butter jelly came from you know
what there's an easy way to make this
game like three times better and that's
every time there's a corpse on the
ground is Mak it Scuttle around like
spider
oh sh receive wow look how Bloody this
three times better their QA process is
pretty
impressive it's like live here's that's
the free to play oh don't kill your
naked mother come on we look at some of
these bodies no you can't if you shoot
them they disappear check all Mor look
how scary it is though oh what is it an
xrays five fingers
neck oh what's over here okay oh rip
cage what other game should they turn
into freeo playay first person
shooters nothing cuz how about
Cameo banjo kazui obviously Viva
Pinata
well all right fear at least had shooter
it was a shooter right there were guns
fear was good
yeah I got grenades now don't be
afraid Andy yeah I'm sorry I know you
want to keep playing this I'm almost
done he is almost done he's killing all
the blop soldiers look all those
blocks I got reviews to edit anyway so
if you want stop we can stop if you want
a review of fear
online this is
it oh what yep yep you fail the
tutorial first encounter assault Recon
on the Internet available now via
steam.com steampowered.com
or fear all.net f f.net are you a f file
don't be afraid it's me P zero in on F
take that keyboard
my wait I'm still playing no
all4 all right we have one more scary
thing to do Andy as the bringer of the
best game we played on the stream today
could you read out the winner of our
Xbox One with Sunset
Overdrive b Diddy
Tampa that Xbox One and Sunset Overdrive
is on the way I can only assume to
Florida so congratulations congrat you
well done gentlemen thank you for
sitting through whatever this was with
me for the past four hours you got
Halloween plans Danny and yeah I'm going
to a thing I'm going to a party thing me
too on pier 70 I need to get a I'm not
going to that kind of party I'm like a
house party but I need to figure out a
costume house 70 what do you think what
should I dress as I'm going to prty in
your neighborhood actually Larry Bird
Larry Bird all right
suggestion mail I'm going to go as a
young gentleman wearing a terrible hat
covered in Old Man pubes mission
accomplished oh yeah bit of mid drift
there for
you that that's against twitch's new
terms of service oh it is I just broke
it this is pulling my shirt down oh gosh
this is legit he's just going to keep
spinning and the microphone's going to
get wound up and then he's not going to
be able to leave but that's fine he's
going to be playing let's close this out
I got to go edit that was a show thank
you very much for everyone for watching
happy Halloween happy Halloween
everybody in the back t play some scary
games Jos you guys are the best and uh
yeah thanks to everyone in the back for
for putting up with our nonsense and
yeah gamespot.com next week we have a
WWE wrestler on uh on the stage what
Ro Roman goddamn Reigns is coming in is
it going to be one of those situations
where you like stand next to an actual
professional athlete and you're like how
do they make people this big I thought I
was like a dude of above average size we
us nothing a scale just in case
excellent and he's getting whole new
lenses for the cameras see what happens
yeah fantastic yeah all right let's all
throw our hats at the cameras in
dramatic fashion adios see you on
gayot.com
bye